here we go again Sony have revealed the
six three games we'll be getting as
PlayStation Plus subscribers for the
month of November 2018 all these games
will be available from Tuesday the 6th
of November usually around midday
depending on when the store updates
anyway you ready let's do this the leaks
were right the two headlining games for
the month are indeed bullets DOM and
Yakuza cooiiy let's break them down
Yakuza kawar me is the 2017 remake of
the original Yakuza game released back
in 2006 damn I feel old as the name
suggests we're taking part in organized
crime around Japan we play as Kiryu who
has just got out of prison for a crime
he obviously didn't commit the game
follows the typical pseudo open-world
action RPG elements you'd expect to find
like in games such as Sleeping Dogs or
Saints Row but the key differences here
are the fighting mechanics as our hero
uses multiple fighting styles upgrading
abilities and thus unlock new moves to
perfect
there's also strange Japanese games to
earn take part in like um this woman's
new earth naked fighting to him and
enjoy Oh before I get sidetracked so if
you've missed the Yakuza series first
time around then kiwami is the perfect
entry point for you retelling the story
of the first installment of the
franchise the scores of 8 and above from
most major games outlets shows us that
accuser kiwami is a great game to play
are you downloading it let us know in
the comments next we have bullet storm
first released back in 2011 this is the
updated full clip edition with upgraded
visuals of this console generation it
even runs at 4k on the ps4 pro this is a
first person shooter filled with gore
and tax less humor my kind of thing as
it first appeared in 2011 little things
break your immersion like the lack of a
jump button which feels alien at first
but the gunplay and the over-the-top
action leashes sets bullets dharm apart
dragging enemies towards you and then
voting them in the skull never gets old
neither does the gratuitous violence who
knew shotgunning limbs off and blowing
enemies into could be so satisfying the
full clip addition includes all
downloadable content from the original
game including the ghost on earth
and blood Symphony with additional
trophies to collect it's uncertain if
will receive a Duke Nukem DLC which was
free to pre-order customers the
re-recorded lines in Dukes voice are
ridiculously fun to hear this game was
adored by critics when it first reviewed
with eights and nines out of 10 across
the board it even picked up the title of
best remaster of 2017 from Game Informer
Bulletstorm full clip edition what do
you think over to the ps3 which as a
reminder will not be supported past
March next year so enjoy the last few
months of ps3 and Vita titles first up
is Jack box party part 2 this is a party
game box set essentially small games
only a few minutes in length like
doodling on your phone and filling in
the blanks in a sentence nothing much
more to say really here
moving on oh okay it must be a minigame
month on ps3 ok da series yeah it's more
minigames but this one is more video
game based so expect platforming and
games like Tetris and Bubble Bobble that
sort of thing
over on the Vita are two more games
which are playable on your ps4 first up
is the brilliantly titled burly men at
sea this is a minimalist adventure title
with gameplay described as midway
between visual novel and point-and-click
adventure you play as a storyteller
shaping a custom tale people talk about
how the story evolves in unique ways I
haven't played this one though but it
does sound interesting okay here's
something absolutely bonkers for the
last game of the month this is round
about in this one you drive a limo
picking up power-ups collecting
passengers and all that kind of thing
I'm sure you've seen the twist the limo
spins literally it can't jump too
ridiculous I know but I personally can't
wait to try this one out reviews go as
low as 5 point 5 out of 10 up to a
massive 7.5 from those pro gamers over
at polygon what do you think gonna give
it a try so there we have it 6 games to
get our teeth into over November I'm
going to dive back into Yakuza after 10
years away from the series and yeah I'm
gonna try roundabout it looks the right
kind of stupid to me but my opinions
mean nothing anyway what are you trying
this month I'd love to know your
thoughts I'm Adam from PlayStation
granade it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
you